how's it going everybody it's Warren and
I'm super excited today because we have
an Avengers in game plot leak that is
probably the most accurate plot leak
that has surfaced so far the plot league
comes from a source that is directly
connected to marketing for movies
including Avengers in game and it lines
up with every single hint clue and leak
that we know about Avengers in game so
I'm really excited for this one
obviously disclaimer it may not be real
just like any other plot leaked that is
out there could be true could not be
true but like I said I believe this one
to be the most accurate for what we're
going to see an Avengers end game also
if you're new to my channel I'm doing a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet giveaway if
you would like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero I'll be
picking a new winner at the end of this
month okay so like I said this plot leak
comes from direct marketing for Avengers
in game so it states the directors
Anthony and Joe Russo of course and it
says who all stars in the movie Robert
Downey jr. Chris Evans Chris Hemsworth
Mark Ruffalo Scarlett Johansson Josh
Brolin etc etc after it gives all of the
credits of all who are involved in the
movie it gives us the plot so I'm just
going to read it all the way through and
then I'll break it down after the final
installment in the Avengers series of
films from Marvel Studios as well as the
final film in Phase three of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in the aftermath of
the events of infinity war where
intergalactic despo Thanos succeeded in
destroying half of all life across the
universe
Earth's Mightiest Heroes are left in
tatters with half of their forces having
been disintegrated but the remaining
heroes have no choice but to fight back
any way they know how no matter how
hopeless it may seem a weakened Tony
Stark reassembles the remaining living
Avengers including Captain America Black
Widow the Hulk and Thor with a plan to
build his own Infinity Gauntlet similar
to the one that allowed Thanos to cause
mass destruction and undo everything
that Thanos wrought recruiting ant-man
to help travel through time and space
using the quantum realm the remaining
Avengers now attempt to go back in there
own timelines and retrieve the Infinity
stones from different periods but as
Thanos soon discovers the plan he is
hell-bent on stopping it even as
timeline alterations now restored
previously lost people and items such as
Thor's hammer Mjolnir
now wilted by Captain America but even
with the help of every hero they can
gather including the guardians of the
galaxy and the infinitely powerful
Captain Marvel the Avengers will face
down Thanos in the decisive battle for
the fate of the universe and one in
which not every member of the team will
ultimately survive so that's the full
plot leaked now let's go back and talk
about some of the key plot points that
were mentioned in the beginning it says
that the remaining heroes have no choice
but to fight back any way they know how
no matter how hopeless it may seem now
it's pretty obvious that the Avengers
are going to fight back somehow and try
to undo the snap but the way this is
worded sets up time travel any way they
know how and no matter how hopeless it
may seem the only way that they can undo
the snap is if they collect all of the
Infinity stones and use them together to
bring everybody back the Avengers have
no idea where fan OSes so they can't
collect Thanos's Infinity stones to undo
the snap so the only option is time
travel but obviously time travel is
something that doesn't seem possible in
reality but that's what they're talking
about here where it says anyway they
know how no matter how hopeless it may
seem time travel is the only way that
they know they can undo the snap but it
hasn't been invented or discovered yet
so it's kind of a hopeless cause the
next part says a weakened Tony Stark
recruits the remaining Avengers so
obviously he gets back somehow he's not
gonna spend the entire movie in space
stranded and when he gets back he's
going to recruit the remaining original
Avengers and his plan is to create his
own Infinity Gauntlet to undo the noses
snap this is something that has been
predicted to happen for a very long time
The Avengers aren't strong enough to
wield the Infinity stones they will need
a gauntlet just like fan o's hat based
off of all the information that they
know together about the Infinity stones
they know that this is the route they'll
have to go and then of course Ant Man
comes in and introduces time-travel to
them via the quantum realm and then of
course that's how they decide how
they'll get their own Infinity stones
going back in time and collecting them
but then it says that thing
soon discovers their plan and is
hell-bent on stopping them they know
still has the Infinity Gauntlet and all
of the Infinity stones and we see in the
trailer that he still has the Infinity
Gauntlet on so he probably uses the
power of all the Infinity stones to
check in and see what the Avengers are
up to Danis believe that his whole
entire destiny was to balance the
universe and he's finally accomplished
his goal thanks to the Infinity Gauntlet
so when he finds out that the Avengers
are trying to undo his snap of course
he's going to be hell-bent on stopping
them but what's really cool is the next
part that talks about what happens when
they travel back in time so according to
this they're sticking to the butterfly
effect meaning that the events that they
change in the past will affect the
future and it says here that as they go
into the past and change things they
restore previously lost people and items
such as Thor's hammer Mjolnir this is
obviously a strategic move and the
Avengers are going to have to be super
careful on what they change in the past
but they know that they're going to need
all the help that they can get so it
makes sense that as they go back in time
they decide to change events to make
some characters come back to life and of
course it makes sense that Thor would go
back in time and get mule near and in
Avengers age of Ultron we saw Captain
America move the hammer just a little
bit I think everybody agrees that he's
worthy enough to lift mule near there
just wasn't a need for it at the time
but now that there is definitely a need
I believe he will have mule near and
Avengers in game and then it says even
with the help of every hero they can
gather this actually implies that there
will be new characters introduced maybe
some of the young Avengers that have
been speculated to appear in Avengers in
game and maybe characters like Black
Knight who has also been speculated to
appear in the movie the Russo brothers
themselves said that there will be new
characters in the movie that have been
in the comics but have not been in the
MCU yet so new characters are expected
and then of course the last part says
that it will be a decisive battle for
the fate of the universe one in which
not every member of the team will
ultimately survive of course it's been
speculated for a very long time now that
somebody will die permanently an
Avengers in game obviously people think
that it's going to be Captain America or
Iron Man both of the actors contracts
are up so of course it's believed that
they're going to be the ones that
bite the dust I don't want to speculate
too much because a lot of people have
been doing that lately talking about who
is going to die but this plot leaked
says that some of the heroes will die so
that's this brand new plot leaked like I
said I believe it to be the most
accurate that we've gotten so far but
let me know what you all think about
this what part of this plot leak makes
you most excited to see Avengers in game
let me know in the comments down below
and of course don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway for the Infinity
Gauntlet and stay up to date on
everything related to Avengers in game
as always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you